les explications de nadège abderrazak la
majorité présidentielle répond très
favorablement à l'initiative de renaud
muselier
cette petite phrase de jean castex a
fait l'effet d'une bombe hier dans le
journal du dimanche
elle annonce en effet le retrait de la
liste et l'hérault m au premier tour des
élections régionales en provence alpes
côte d'azur au profit du président ait
l'air sortant de la région et la
sanction n'a pas tardé
du côté des républicains après l'annonce
des petites manoeuvres électorales en
paca par monsieur castex renaud muselier
conformément aux règles des républicains
qui impose qu'il n'y a aucun accord de
premier tour avec l om ne pourra pas
bénéficier de l'investiture et l'air
c'est lui qui s'estime être le candidat
le plus à même de l'emporter se défend
de toute trahison
il faut tout faire pour que la région ne
tombe pas aux mains d'un parti
extrémiste
j'ai fait appel au soutien le plus large
je pense que le dépassement est
impératif pour des élections locales
le premier ministre a répondu
positivement et annoncé le retrait d'une
candidature gouvernementale cette liste
sera d'abord celle de la majorité
actuelle plurielle mais le mal est fait
pour une partie des élus les
républicains certains affirment qu'il
s'agit là d'un coup monté par l'elysée
pour faire taire toute opposition celle
de droite en particulier immense
tristesse face à ce coup de poignard
dans le dos je le savais dès avant le
premier tour de la présidentielle
ils préparaient leur mauvaise soupe sur
le petit feu élyséen dans la mauvaise
marmite en marche
muselier enlève le masque et assume de
se soumettre à macron les 20 et 27 juin
renvoyer les républicains en marche aux
poubelles de l'histoire reste à savoir
maintenant si après le retrait de
l'investiture de renaud muselier les
républicains décident d'investir un
autre candidat
ce scénario pourrait comporter un risque
celui de diviser l'électorat de la
droite et du centre en paca au profit de
thierry mariani
ancien et l'air devenue tête de liste du
rassemblement national alors en scellant
ce rapprochement entre la majorité
présidentielle et les républicains pour
les régionales en paca renaud muselier
at-il condamné la droite au silence at
il une pire signé la fin des
républicains c'est l'objet de notre face
à face ce soir est avec nous pour en
débattre jean paul garraud député
européen rn1 tête de liste et rennes en
occitanie aux régions aux élections
régionales justement bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous à vos côtés jacques
myard mer et l'air de maisons laffitte
dans les yvelines bonsoir jacques myard
merci à vous également d'être là donc
personne ne peut douter de ma noyauté de
ma fidélité a dit renaud muselier cet
après-midi en tant que membre du parti
les républicains jacques myard vous le
prenez comment vous c'est une trahison
je crois qu'ils entrent et là maintenant
perdre parce que aujourd'hui essayer des
élections avec elle est réellement c'est
abouti et aux vagues on a un père pour
regarder les choses et je n'ai pas
accroché et donc on finit aujourd'hui
assigné je vous donnez moi je suis
vraiment désolé je suis obligé d'être
mal élevé de vous couper parce que la
liaison est très mauvaise alors on va
donner en attendant la parole à jean
paul garraud en espérant vous retrouver
avec un son correct de façon à entendre
ce que vous nous dites parce que c'est
très important vous jean paul garraud
quel est votre sentiment sur cette
affaire quand vous voyez ça de
l'extérieur mais pas que parce qu'on
sait qu'il y aura des conséquences
évidemment très importante
incontournable sur votre parti le
rassemblement national notamment en paca
d'abord écouté je souhaitais
simplement c'est lui et jacques myard
que je connais très bien puisque nous
avons siégé en sort de l'assemblée
nationale sur les mêmes bandes j'étais
député ump
et si je suis où je suis aujourd'hui
c'est à dire que je suis député européen
élu sur une liste du rassemblement
national c'est parce que justement je
savais que tôt ou tard les élèves
allaient arriver dans la situation dans
laquelle ils se trouvent aujourd'hui
c'est à dire qu'une fois de plus les
nerfs se déchirent
vous avez d'un côté dlr à qui donc qui
d'ailleurs une majorité du dlr dans mon
si je puis dire qu'ils s'allient avec
donc la république en marche parce
qu'ils sont heureux
cherchez disons des postes ministériels
quelques avantages conserver le pouvoir
qu'ils sont ils estiment qu'en s'alliant
avec évidemment la république en marche
i zal ils vont pouvoir
électoralement garder ce qu'ils ont
c'est le cas de renaud muselier et puis
vous avez une partie non négligeable
également dlr
c'est plutôt les l'air d'en bas ce
seront plutôt les adhérents les
militants ce sont plutôt ceux qui sont
vraiment sur le terrain
et bien que je ne supporte pas
effectivement ce rapprochement avec en
marche qui sont plutôt eux qui ont
plutôt un héritage
pauline sales un héritage j'ai tiré de
l'ancien rpr start et qu'il se retrouve
l'opus passons dans cette politique
macro nice et physique est complètement
à l'envers naturellement de d'une
politique gaulliste si je puis dire
donc ceci fait que nous sommes dans une
situation guère sont dans une situation
qui les condamne à l'échec et c'est la
raison principale pour laquelle donc je
n'ai pas voulu rester dans ce parti
parce que derrière assez ces histoires
d'appareils je dirais il y a le sort de
la france et je sais très bien que
jacques myard et ceci en premier souci
ou si nous avons nous avons souvent
parlé et nous avons les mêmes
aspirations d'ailleurs jacques et et
s'étire ensemble à l'assemblée
nous étions un peu à la droite populaire
donc que nous avions fondé avec thierry
mariani thierry mariani
jacques viens moi-même donc nous étions
mais d'autres nous étions tous
d'ailleurs avec plus de 40 députés de la
droite populaire et on avait créé ce
mouvement de la droite populaire en 2010
pour déjà à l'époque à faire en sorte
peser en quelque sorte sur nicolas
sarkozy promenade au bout des promesses
électorales de 2007 donc déjà à l'époque
nous voyons bien cette évolution de
l'ump puis dlr une branche plus tôt
droite hors des orléanistes en quelque
sorte qu'ils se rapprochent du centre et
une autre plus bonapartiste et peu
sortent aussi qui voit bien les
problèmes de la société actuelle qui
voit bien les explosions les tensions
qui maintenant nous justement nous
éclater à la figure et et qui cherche
effectivement des solutions ils soient
les solutions d'une pratique
jacques myard c'est parce que vous avez
entendu tontouta réponse ce soir mais
c'est dur ce qui vous dit finalement
jean paul garraud parce qu'en gros parce
que oui mais vous dit il est finalement
ils n'avaient pas de choix ton temps ils
se retrouveraient dans cette cité
jean-paul je le connais bien il a pris
effectivement une décision d'aller dans
un sens mais il n'ya pas que paca et il
n'y a pas que son cas personnel ce qui
est en cause
en réalité c'est effectivement de passer
le premier région sont des régionales or
qu'est-ce que tu as tes vous constatez
d'une part que ça soit valérie pécresse
en région parisienne que ce soit xavier
bertrand dans le nord que ce soit
laurent wauquiez en rhône alpes
c'est qu'ils sont sur la ligne où les
nerfs se bat sur leur drapeau et ne vont
pas faire et la gouille avec notamment
les rêves parce que c'est une question
de cohérence
c'est une question de logique
aujourd'hui est bon jean paul appui et
une voix et fabienne mais moi je sais
mes électeurs
reconnaissent en temps le lr tort
j'allais dire oh le long terme et aussi
aux listes depuis très longtemps et donc
je reste dans cette famille alors
thierry mariani que je peux très bien
jean-paul que je tenais bien ont choisi
une autre voie
je la respecte je la respecte et vous
savez là la politique nous échapper un
long fleuve tranquille
et rien ne dit pas fin se retrouvent
états lorsqu'ils auront été à nouveau
leurs engagements actuels et seront
reconnus à diou alors on va se lancer le
débat messieurs
renaud muselier s'est défendu cet après
midi je vous propose de le réécouter on
a déjà écouté cette extrême il important
dans ce reportage je n'ai déjà des
ravages vous propose de réécouter renaud
muselier sur sur ce point qui vous
concerne peut-être jean paul garraud
région ne tombe pas aux mains d'un parti
extrémiste
j'ai fait appel au soutien le plus large
je pense que le dépassement est
impératif pour des élections locales
le premier ministre a répondu
positivement et annoncé le retrait d'une
candidature gouvernementale cette liste
sera d'abord celle de la majorité
actuelle pluriel alors évidemment c'est
votre parti jean paul garraud le n 1 qui
est clairement visé c'est une alliance
qui peut se produire dans d'autres
régions et est menacée mine de rien vous
vos candidats m'écouter d'avoir bon je
connais bien aussi renaud muselier et
j'ai beaucoup et j'ai l'habitude
d'ailleurs pour lui mais je ne suis pas
un parti extrémiste
voilà ça c'est dit si vous voulez c'est
une c'est une sorte de d'expressions
communes qui est là simplement pour je
ne sais pas pour cataloguer pour essayer
de faire peur jacques mme jacqueline
connais très bien je n'ai jamais été
excessif en quoi que ce soit je suis
magistrat pendant 30 ans j'ai été sur le
terrain et j'ai tellement vu monter ce
qui allait nous arrive
et que j'ai pris la décision que j'ai
prise justement pour la france en fait
et je sais que fondamentalement nous
pensons la même chose et c'est cela il
faut trouver une solution si vous voyez
en occitanie que je suis à présent et
bien déjà en 2015 nous avions avec les
républicains le rassemblement national
fait le front national à l'époque et les
républicains nous sommes à 55 % en 2015
au jour d'aujourd'hui nous sommes
certainement encore plus haut eh bien à
chaque fois on se débrouille pour perdre
alors qu'on est majoritaire et c'est
exactement la même chose dans le pays
alors si elle ne se serait pas très
grave si c'était uniquement des
histoires d'appareils mais derrière
c'est la politique de la france qui en
pâtit et moi ce que je dis simplement
c'est que je ne demande pas ce que tout
le monde vienne au rassemblement
national pas du tout moi même d'ailleurs
je n'ai pas ma carte au rassemblement
national mais ce que j'ai demandé
simplement c'est qu'on ne s'interdisent
pas des alliances les alliances
électorales
c'est à dire ce que à gauche ils font
depuis très longtemps le piège évité
randien fonctionne toujours c'est
extraordinaire françois mitterrand donc
avait sorti à l'époque mais c'est vrai
qu'à l'époque ce n'était pas le
rassemblement de national d'aujourd'hui
mais ça fonctionne toujours
ce rejet cet ostracisme ce qui consiste
à faire peur à a barré la route à une
sorte de mouvement qui serait
antidémocratique c'est faux le
rassemblement national aujourd'hui
honnêtement je ne vois pas de différence
avec le rpr chargé quelques inconnues
voilà donc évidemment ceci n'est pas
n'est pas évolué et nous avons aussi des
programmes beaucoup de choses donc
jacques myard je vais vous faire la
guerre mais justement sur ces petits
arrangements entre amis là je vous
taquine un peu mais enfin emmanuel
macron on doit certainement se frotter
les mains de son côté écouter ce qu'on
dit gabriel
à thann le porte parole du gouvernement
en vente vous fait réagir jacques myard
c'est dans notre adn
on s'est engagé en 2010 est derrière
l'idée du dépassement politique et le
fait que les hommes et femmes ne sont
pas prisonniers derrière des étiquettes
politiques et on assiste aujourd'hui à
une nouvelle étape de ce dépassement au
niveau local mais aussi à une
clarification au niveau national pour
les républicains
jacques myard clairement c'est ce que
vous craignez parce que gabriella talent
sont en tant qu on est dans une nouvelle
étape et qui en aura d'autres alors je
vais vous dire je vais vous dire une
chose
monsieur attal vie et dans je dirais une
sorte de mythe qui n'existe pas pourquoi
parce que aujourd'hui les gens qui le
chantpie avec eux au gouvernement ne
représente rien
qu'est ce que représente sur le plan
électoral bruno le maire rien qu'est ce
que représente monsieur darmanin rien
ils n'ont pas de base électorale ce qui
peut se passer pour gouverner la france
c'est effectivement une question de
projet politique et ce projet politique
il est clair que je peux avoir décidé de
souveraineté de politique industrielle
sécurité d'indépendance de la politique
étrangère partager avec d'autres
mais je les défends avec ce que je suis
et donc c'est la raison pour laquelle
ont tenu de ce que pensent mais les
électeurs qui m'ont élu je reste fidèle
à pons rapeau alors maintenant est ce
que ça veut dire que les choses vont
rester à bitam en état je n'en sais rien
mais il est possible effectivement que
monsieur garraud rejoignent et
souverainistes boulistes peu mou mois
pour qu'on puisse continuer le combat et
ses procès la raison pour laquelle je ne
lance pas d'un hatem a dit karl ont pris
une autre voie
mais je leur dis attention c'est qu'il
faudra gouverner la france avec des gens
qui tiennent la barre
je suis sûr que pour baby garraud est
capable de remplir des missions
je ne suis pas sûr que tous aux airelles
soit capable de tenir
bah alors la réponse de jean paul
garraud dit votre ami mais non mais
écoutez c'est très simple je suis
d'accord avec ce que dit jacques bien
sur le fond sur le fond on est
totalement d'accord il a évoqué la
souveraineté bien entendu il à la place
de la france à la sécurité l'identité
notre histoire enfin tout ce qui est
battue en brèche aujourd'hui donc l'idée
l'idée quand même c'est de gagner
d'arriver à gagner à gagner ensemble
marine le pen est la première à dire
qu'il faut un gouvernement d'union
nationale avec des gens qui ne jette pas
des anneaux thème avec des gens qui sont
évidemment qu'ils ont les mêmes
réflexions que nous et qui voit bien
qu'il faut arriver au pouvoir c'est
absolument vital
alors moi j'ai beaucoup de respect pour
jacques mais il sait très bien qu'il
n'ya pas de candidat actuellement qui
est capable de remporter l'élection
présidentielle dans le mouvement
l air que lui chaque ligne 1 représente
je parle dlr qui sont pas macro
compatibles parce que je sais que
jacques myard n'est pas du tout ma
chrome compatible bon donc kiki aux
républicains est en position aujourd'hui
de gagner je tends viennent gagner la
présidentielle
et bien malheureusement il n'y a
personne malheureusement pour les
républicains
donc il faut faire un peu de politique
de réaliste moi je demande simplement à
ce qu'on me croit là où je suis
aujourd'hui je travaille avec des gens
intéressants avec les cheveux je fais de
vrais programmes
je construis de vrais programmes par
exemple en ce qui vous concerne eh bien
j'ai mis en place donc le livre blanc
sur la sécurité sur la justice
j'ai mis en place le contre projet sur
l'islamisme
ce sont des sujets sur lequel j'ai
toujours travaillé toujours y compris
quand j'étais et jacques myard le sait
très bien compris quand j'étais
évidemment à l'ump
malheureusement on n'est pas arrivé là
où on aurait souhaité surtout quand au
long de monsieur hollande est arrivé
avec madame taubira
ils ont tous mis par terre un de ce
qu'on avait pu faire et puis on n'était
pas allé peut-être jusqu'au bout pour un
certain nombre de raisons au jour
d'aujourd'hui c'est urgent
ce qui gouverne donc c'est pas à moi de
venir c'est jacques et qui doit venir
vers nous ce sera qui or on arrivera à
mon goût du débat très rapidement là où
personne pour gagner incapable de gagner
à droite chez vous à la fin mai alors
c'est très simple on va franchir le cap
des régionales et il y aura un candidat
mais où je suis d'accord avec jean paul
sait qu'il peut pas y en avoir deux et
donc pour arriver à redresser la barre
il va falloir qui vient un candidat ait
l'air et royer moi c'est possible on a
des hommes de talent est là jean-paul
reviendra doux et des femmes de talent
j'imagine aussi merci aux débats après
après les régionales merci en tout cas à
vous 2 jean paul garraud et jacques
milliards d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france sur le front de la
crise sanitaire à présent première étape
aujourd'hui du déconfinement progressif
avec la fin des restrictions de
déplacement et de l'ami d'une limite des
10 km le retour des collégiens et
lycéens en présentiel pour plus de
précisions nous retrouvons david khalifa
en direct du ministère de la santé
bonsoir david kelly phare une seconde
étape donc pour l'éducation nationale
aujourd'hui une satisfaction affichée
par l'exécutif et pourtant dans les
faits les moyens manquent encore
cruellement pour respecter le protocole
sanitaire
effectivement stéphanie ce même de
l'autosatisfaction affichée par jean
michel blanquer et jean castex ce matin
présent dans le lycée professionnel de
laxou en mer te mau en
meurthe-et-moselle rouvert en 2012 comme
la plupart des collèges et des lycées en
france cette rentrée marque le
déploiement progressif des fameux les
autotests nouvelles armes de l'exécutif
pour contrôler est la pandémie en milieu
scolaire en prenant exemple sur ce qui
s'est déroulé à la semaine dernière dans
les écoles elle jean castex estime que
tout s'est très bien passé et qu'il en
sera de même pour le secondaire écouter
notre objectif reste le même l'objectif
politique majeur c'est de faire en sorte
que les écoles les établissements
scolaires fonctionnent le plus possible
le service public de l'éducation
nationale est stratégique dans cette
pandémie
la france peut s'enorgueillir d'être un
des pays au monde au monde où les écoles
et lycées des collèges auront le plus
fonctionner et nous voulons continuer
cela une exigence une très grande
sécurité la plus grande sécurité
possible
le protocole le déploiement des tests il
ya eu des tests andy génie qui a les
tests salivaires
il ya des autotests ya toutes les
techniques qui sont à notre disposition
pour assurer une surveillance la plus
renforcée possible et une sécurité la
plus approfondie possible au bénéfice de
l'ensemble de la communauté éducative
c'est à dire des élèves et des
enseignants
des déclarations qui ne sont pas
véritablement en adéquation à mettre ce
qui s'est réellement passé
aujourd'hui de nombreux lycées et
collèges n'ont pas reçu et c'est un
fameux test ajoutez à ça de l'inquiétude
pour les enseignants concernant
notamment la vaccination et david les
principaux reproches en fait par les
personnels de l'éducation nationale
c'est encore une fois que l'exécutif n'a
pas anticipé cette rentrée
oui le protocole sanitaire est très
stricte et ce matin dans les lycées et
collèges la plupart des professeurs
étaient mitigées voire désabusé puisque
rien n'a été mise en place dans certains
établissements scolaires c'est le cas à
levallois-perret en région parisienne
elle marion petit fils professeur de
mathématiques dans ce collège estime que
le gouvernement aurait pu faire plus
durant le temps du confinement écoutez
c'est plus qu'une impression c'est un
constat c'est que effectivement sur la
vaccination sur les tests vois je vous
dis 1 ce matin y'a rien qui ait mis en
place il ya aucun test du pour les
élèves du pour les enseignants alors
peut-être que ça va venir mais c'est que
ça fait quatre semaines
de la même façon je vous dis ma
messagerie de le nc ne fonctionnait
toujours pas la fin de la semaine
dernière alors que ces quatre semaines
et que ça fait un an qu'on sait qu'il ya
des problèmes sur ses plates formes donc
donc oui c'est un constat que pas grand
chose a été fait et c'est là où c'est
vraiment là où je suis vraiment en
colère c'est que c'est que ces quatre
semaines elles auraient pu être utiles
et un peu d'appréhension parce que voilà
ça veut dire qu on se trouve là je vois
des élèves ce matin demain il y aura un
cas positif et je les vois plus pendant
une semaine donc il ya forcément un peu
d'appréhension par rapport à ça
de l'appréhension vous l'avez entendu un
risque de fermeture qui pèse toujours un
sur elles étaient des établissements
scolaires un retard conséquent également
dans la vaccination des professeurs
actuellement environ 20% des enseignants
de plus de 55 ans ont reçu une première
dose depuis la mi avril soit plus de
35000 personnes un taux très faible en
comparaison au nombre total
d'enseignants et de personnels de
l'éducation nationale estimée à près
d'un million tous ces éléments ne
rassure pas sur la fin d'année scolaire
évidemment merci david khalifa en direct
donc du ministère de l'éducation
nationale ce soir les terrasses des
cafés des restaurants rouvriront quant à
elle le 19 mai
échéance très attendue par les
professionnels du secteur qui
conserveront leur indemnisation
ceux qui rêvent rire ont partiellement
seront éligibles au fonds de solidarité
même si leurs pertes de chiffres
d'affaires sont inférieurs à 50% selon
les mots du ministre de l'éducation ce
matin bruno le maire qui rencontre cet
après-midi hôteliers et restaurateurs
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons de la flambée épidémique
en inde cette fois près de 20 millions
de contaminations au coc u19 une
progression attribuée à direction du
premier ministre
narendra modi dont le parti vient
d'essuyer une défaite électorale dans
l'état du bengale occidental
et puis nous évoquerons les 100 ans du
rap ogre attachement de l'irlande du
nord au royaume uni un anniversaire qui
divisent toujours
[Musique]
notre société vit un moment très
important dans la lutte contre les
violences de l'intimé violence de la
maison il y à chaque année 300 mille
personnes victimes de violences
sexuelles
70% des plaintes classées sans suite et
un nombre de condamnations
d'ailleurs en baisse mais autour de 1000
condamnation par an nous devons
progresser de deux manières la première
c'est par la loi et ensuite progresser
parce que nous appelons des pratiques
professionnelles protectrice la justice
à sa part dans cette impunité
comment souhaitez vous la faire évoluer
nous devons être concret pour que la
protection ne soit pas un mot mais une
réalité
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que notre peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez comme moi qui ai des gandhi il n'y
a pas d'alternative au sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu livrant une forme c'est quand même
des hommes comment ces mecs-là arrive à
dormir la nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a
vécu quelque chose d'inouï gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite c'était
les gens qui travaillent c'est les gens
qui avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose à leurs enfants qui
le droit qui doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer qu une
sixième république qui ne soit pas
l'oublié parlementaire ça se passe en
direct puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté je vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
le théâtre du châtelet sépare théâtre
comme les autres c'est un théâtre qui
est très diversifiée dans un
programmation de la culture est une
activité absolument essentiel de notre
société de sa cohésion de sa cohérence
c'est aussi le rôle du châtelet de
pouvoir mettre en contact des très
belles productions avec le public
qu'est ce qu'on fait dans un théâtre en
plein confinement on a essayé de
réinventer notre métier et en
particulier on a fait beaucoup de
travail avec la télévision on a permis
de capter un certain nombre de
spectacles pour la télévision ce qui est
une autre manière de pouvoir créer la
relation avec le public et je suis sûr
qu'il y aura une grande volonté du
public de revenir dans les théâtres
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
c'est un coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent pour l
on soit vient des lignes ont aujourd'hui
une gauche qui extrait de la société
[Musique]
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande île interview on vit tous
les jours sans faire attention que tout
en dépend c'est l'unité de mesure de
toute chose une convention admise par
tous s'il arrive quelque chose tout
s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
20h30 bienvenue sur rt francs si vous
nous rejoignez l'inde submergé par le
virus alors que l'aide internationale
commence à arriver
nouveau record avec près de 3700
personnes décédées en 24 heures ce
week-end c'est le pire bilan enregistré
en une seule journée dans le pays
l'inde qui compte ce jour plus de 215
milles morts liés à la pandémie ont fait
le point sur la situation avec françois
tisci et beach c'est reims appelle les
oxygen express des trains spéciaux
réquisitionnée par le gouvernement
indien afin de transporter des citernes
cryogénique contenant de l'oxygène
médical liquide vers les états redire
les plus touchées reculé avec près de 8
millions de nouveaux cas recensés depuis
mars
l'oxygène manque cruellement dans les
hôpitaux face à la situation
plus de 40 pays ont annoncé envoyer de
l'aide les indiens attendent ce soutien
qui arrivent et qui comprend du matériel
médical essentiel
nous avons vu la mobilisation pour les
concentrateurs d'oxygène l'oxygène
médical
les camions-citernes isolé camions
citernes cryogénique qui ont été
transportés dans le monde entier jusqu
en inde il ya aussi des respirateurs
cela représente beaucoup pointent une
aide précieuse
devant cette clinique de new delhi des
ouvriers des charges l'un des huit
générateurs d'oxygène de grande capacité
envoyé par le gouvernement français une
machine capable de produire de l'oxygène
médical à partir de l'air ambiant et
pouvant alimenter en continu un hôpital
de 256
l'oxygène est l'un des principaux
supports du traitement des patients
atteints du coc vide 19 ils ont besoin
de soutien car xd sature dans toute la
ville il y ait une demande accrue dans
les hôpitaux une machine interne comme
celle ci qui produit 24 heures sur 24 7
jours sur 7 sera d'une grande aide pour
augmenter la capacité
d'approvisionnement afin de combler
l'écart entre les besoins et l'offre
cet équipement permet donc de sauver des
vies dès à présent pénurie d'oxygène
mais également de vaccins jusqu'à
présent environ 150 millions de doses
ont été administrées ce qui représente
11,5 pour cent de la population est à
peine 25 millions d'habitants ont reçu
leurs deux injections
pourtant le pays a ouvert ce samedi sa
campagne de vaccination à l'ensemble de
ses 600 millions d'habitants le
gouvernement du premier ministre à
rennes drame audi critiqué pour sa
gestion de la pandémie est plus que
jamais sous pression
de nombreuses voix réclamant un
confinement nationale une pression
accentuée après sa défaite dimanche aux
élections législatives dans l'état du
bengale occidental et pour en parler
nous sommes avec toute blanche maison
expert en relations internationales
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous on
vient de voir un vin qui est frappée
très cruellement croire cette vague
épidémique hors de contrôle une donnée
qui est important dans ce pays puisqu'il
est peuplé de 1,3 milliard d'habitants
mais cela n'explique pas tout n'est ce
pas oui en effet le prochain recensement
fera probablement apparaître que l'inde
est devenue le pays le plus peuplé du
monde avec probablement plus d'habitants
que que la chine mais l'un c'est aussi
le pays où coexistent les technologies
et elle est plus les plus sûrs et plus
sophistiquée la haute technologie avec
la pauvreté absolue
c'est aussi le pays où une
administration tatillonne
coexistent avec des hommes d'affaires
extrêmement innovant c'est d'ailleurs
eux qui ont construit cette capacité de
fabriquer des vaccins qui est la
première au monde sans aucun conteste et
bien le système sanitaire indien il est
à l'image de cette société il y a d'un
côté des hôpitaux privés qui sont assez
bien équipé mais dont les prix sont hors
de portée pour la plupart de la
population des hôpitaux publics qui eux
sont mal équipés parce que les
gouvernements successifs n'ont pas fait
les investissements suffisants à
l'exception peut-être de quelques
gouvernements régionaux comme au kerala
et par conséquent on voit ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui pour la production
d'oxygène médical avec une insuffisance
des moyens logistiques pour faire
parvenir cet oxygène de qualité médicale
aux hôpitaux qui en ont besoin
avec le manque de camions équipés des
moyens réfrigérant nécessaire le manque
de capacité de stockage et même le
manque de bouteille
donc ces images de familles désespérées
qui vont acheter au prix fort des
bouteilles chez les revendeurs dans les
différentes villes
et bien ce gouvernement qui est au
pouvoir depuis 2000 14 depuis sept ans
est un gouvernement qui se veut un
doubiste par conséquent monsieur moody a
été dans un premier temps l'année
dernière au début de la première vague
de l'épidémie dans le déni parce qu'il
était impensable que le pays au milieu
de milliers de du de dieu puisse être
soumis à une telle malédiction
et puis voyant ce qui se passait dans
les autres pays dans le monde il a
décrété fin mars l'année dernière un
confinement généralisée très brutale
pendant deux mois mais qui évidemment a
mis l'économie indienne par terre et
donc il s'est juré de ne plus jamais
recommencer
et c'est pour cela qu'aujourd'hui il ne
veut par confiner alors que les experts
considèrent que cette deuxième vague
exigerait un recond finement le dr fauci
le célèbre spécialiste américain dit que
l'inde a besoin d'un confinement absolu
pendant plusieurs semaines
mais comment en est on arrivé là et
pourquoi d'ailleurs cette deuxième vague
est bien parce que ce gouvernement
hindouiste naturellement ne pouvait pas
interdire le plus grand pèlerinage de
l'inde qui a lieu tous les dix ans à
haridwar sur le gange où pendant
plusieurs semaines des millions de
pèlerins sont ensemble agglutinés et
prennent des bains d'eau dans le fleuve
sacré et de la même manière puisqu'il
veut s'assurer du pouvoir dans l'est
dans l'est dans les états qui ne
contrôle pas encore eh bien le même
gouvernement a participé à des meetings
à des réunions politiques dans les
différentes dans les différents états
qui avait des élections le mois dernier
et ses grands meetings évidemment on
était aussi des lieux de contamination
alors vous parlez de cette stratégie du
gouvernement et ses choix il faut
préciser que le parti nationaliste
hindou du premier ministre le bjp a
essuyé un revers électoral dans un état
clé qui fait quand même 90 millions
d'habitants c'est plus que la france
elle même est ce qu'on peut attribuer
cette défaite justement à cette crise du
coronavirus et à sa gestion surtout vous
avez raison c'est une défaite importante
il n'est pas certain qu'elle soit due à
la mauvaise gestion de la pandémie parce
qu'il se trouve que le
bengale-occidental calcutta par
conséquent ont été atteints par la
deuxième vague plus tard que les autres
états est en réalité calcutta et la
région du bengale occidental en général
ce sont des zones avec une grande
tradition intellectuelle une grande
tradition de discussion une tradition
aussi de tolérance il à vis des
différentes religions et puis plus du
tiers de la population est de confession
musulmane alors que en 1/2 la moyenne
est d'environ 14% et par conséquent la
population du bengale occidental a assez
mal pris la politique d'indemnisation à
outrance que monsieur maudit a accéléré
depuis sa réélection triomphale au
printemps 2010 9 avec notamment des lois
qui stigmatise
les musulmans donc il est probable que
madame mamata banerjee qui est le chief
minister de cet état l'un des rares une
des rares femmes chief minister en inde
et qui a beaucoup de charisme comme
d'ailleurs monsieur maudit et bien a
pris le leadership d'une véritable
opposition à ce pouvoir et que
probablement à l'avenir on reparlera
dell a gagné en effet les deux tiers des
sièges à la législation dans la
législature du bengale de l'ouest mais
on a aussi observé une défaite du bjp
dans les deux états du sud qui sont très
importants le tamil nadu et le kerala
alors au kerala il ya une tradition qui
est que le parti communiste indien
alternent au pouvoir avec le parti du
congrès fameux party d'indépendance et
bien là le parti communiste qui était au
pouvoir depuis une législature a été
réélu a été reconduit parce que
probablement en effet ses
investissements dans les hôpitaux font
que le système sanitaire au kerala était
en meilleur état que ailleurs dans
d'autres états de l'inde
et puis au tamil nadu et bien il ya eu
un débat très important entre deux
partis régionaux et c'est finalement
l'un des deux partis régionaux qui l'a
emporté monsieur moody a eu beau faire
de nombreux meetings son ministre de
l'intérieur à bitche a également des
meetings contaminants puisqu'il y avait
beaucoup de gens qui étaient les uns sur
les autres
eh bien ça n'a eu aucun effet puisqu'il
n'ya aucun élu bjp à la chambre du doute
et du tamil nadu et que c'est un certain
monsieur monsieur staline qui n'a rien à
voir avec son homonyme
soviétique qui sera le chief minister du
tamil nadu et kit qui gouverne avec un
parti de centre gauche qui par
conséquent poursuivra la politique du
gouvernement précédent d'un autre parti
régional il ya donc une reconfiguration
de la situation politique en inde une
confirmation que l'inde est un pays
démocratique que le bjp ne peut pas
accueillir tous les pouvoirs et qu' un
certain nombre d'états font de la
résistance et qu'il ya une opposition
n'a alors ce n'est pas nécessairement
celle du parti du congrès ça peut être
aussi celle de partis régionaux et
l'idée régionaux particulièrement fort
alors on ne peut pas évoquer l'un des
clubs blanche maison sans parler du
dispositif kovacs il fait évidemment
largement les frais de la crise en inde
qui est il faut le rappeler le premier
fournisseur du programme international
et ce programme est ce qu'il est
clairement en péril aujourd'hui ce
programme il a été initié par
l'organisation mondiale de la santé et
par l'omg gafi qui doit être jugé pour
la promotion des vaccins qui s'est
chargée elle de recueillir et de
recueillir les dons d'un différend mains
d'un certain nombre de pays de façon à
pouvoir offrir des vaccins gratuit aux
pays qui n'en n'ont pas les moyens et
un milliard a été promis par monsieur
joe biden un milliard de dollars 850
milliards 650 millions au pardon d'euros
ce qui revient à peu près au même
montant pour l'union européenne et puis
un certain nombre de pays à sa tante
d'état ont également promis des sommes
donc les premiers financements sont là
insuffisant a bien entendu monsieur
tedros gebreyesus le directeur général
de l'organisation mondiale de la santé
il voudrait 10 milliards de dollars de
façon pouvoir vacciner tout le monde et
il dit à juste raison que tant qu'il y a
des pays infectés par ce virus est bien
le danger il est général parce qu'on ne
peut pas empêcher la circulation
on peut confier qui l'on veut mais les
gens continueront de circuler et on le
voit bien actuellement avec le variant
indien qui pénètre un peu partout même
sur le territoire français par
conséquent il faut vacciner tout le
monde est en effet monsieur narendra
modi a été contraint de décréter à la
fin du mois de mars un embargo sur
l'exportation des vaccins comme les plus
grandes usines de fabrication de vaccins
se trouve en inde
eh bien il en résulte que le système
kovacs des plus suffisamment
approvisionné en vaccins en réalité ces
livraisons sont différées puisque les
pays les plus riches sont approvisionnés
sur le marché mondial est bien entendu
ont pris ce qui était disponible sur ce
marché par conséquent le système kovacs
vie s'approvisionnera ensuite notamment
essentiellement en inde probablement à
hauteur de plus de la moitié est
évidemment il va y avoir un décalage de
quelques mois et probablement bien sûr
les premières les premières livraisons
ont été faites notamment par la france
en afrique de l'ouest
d'autres livraisons été faite dans
quelques pays africains et d'amérique
latine mais l'essentiel sera fait à la
fin de l'année 2021 et en 2022
merci claude la blanche maison expert en
relations internationales
le continent africain lui a été
relativement épargné par la pandémie
jusqu'ici mais la situation sanitaire
inquiète désormais l'om est ce qu il
craindre un scénario à l'indienne les
experts pointent du doigt les vastes
rassemblements le non respect des
mesures sanitaires et le trop faible
nombre de tests
selon les derniers chiffres l'afrique
enregistré plus de 120 mille décès
depuis le début de la pandémie
nous ne pouvons pas nous laisser bercer
par un faux sentiment de sécurité
l'augmentation dévastatrice des cas et
des décès en inde et le rebond manifeste
observée dans d'autres régions du monde
sont des signes clairs que la pandémie
n'est pas encore terminée dans les pays
africains
une nouvelle remontée des infections par
le cos vie 19 est un risque réel dans de
nombreux pays même si le nombre de cas
dans la région semble stable ces
dernières semaines répond lutter contre
le virus l'ouganda a suspendu tous les
vols en provenance d'inde après un
premier cas de variants ce pays
d'afrique de l'est a lancé sa campagne
de vaccination contre le coc vide le 10
mars en ciblant plus de 20 millions de
personnes soit la moitié de la
population
à ce jour plus de 300000 ougandais ont
reçu une première dose du vaccin mais
certaines zones sont plus difficiles
d'accès en quel point avec hélène
masquelier atteindre des centaines de
personnes vulnérables dans les zones
rurales
un défi majeur pour la campagne de
vaccination en ouganda le lac boni yayi
se trouve dans le sud ouest du pays
parsemé d'îles seo abrite quelques 2500
habitants
c'est l'un des endroits les plus
difficiles d'accès du pays notamment
pour le personnel médical basé sur l'île
de batz noir pour chaque action de
proximité que nous faisons ici nous
devons traverser le lac
chaque patient qui vient ici doit aussi
traversé le lac cela signifie que sans
utiliser de bateaux vous ne pouvez pas
accéder aux centres de santé et aux
services médicaux
cela nécessite plusieurs choses l'argent
ou alors des ressources en carburant si
vous n'avez pas d'argent vous ne pouvez
pas vous déplacer pour recevoir des
soins
atteindre les îles environnantes
implique une traversée au moins de 30
minutes en bateau soit sur un canot et
traditionnelles ou à bord d'un bateau
moteur bien plus coûteux les vaccins
sont ainsi transporté au travers du lac
dans une simple glaciaire une avancée
néanmoins pour cette zone qui ne
disposait pas de fonds suffisants pour
débuter une campagne de vaccination au
centre de santé bien ma 3 il n'avait pas
encore commencé la vaccination contre le
colis de 19 alors que le gouvernement
l'a lancée le 10 mars mais le district
nous a expliqué que le transport
constitue une limite car les vaccins
doivent être acheminés depuis le
district pour qu'un bateau fasse un
aller-retour pour venir jusqu'ici cela
coûte la somme de 28 dollar est
effectivement une telle somme n'est pas
à la portée de tous et à l'épaule la
pandémie de kobe 19 a rendu la situation
encore plus difficile pour les habitants
de l'île lesquels compte en temps normal
sur le tourisme comme source de revenus
l'exercice à bas noir a permis à plus de
200 personnes de se faire vacciner dès
mercredi premier jour de la distribution
les autorités espèrent vacciner mille
personnes parmi les plus vulnérables sur
ces îles selon les chiffres officiels le
pays déplore seulement près de 40000 car
pour plus de 334 décès
dans le reste de l'actualité l'irlande
du nord célèbre aujourd'hui ses 100 ans
un centenaire avec en toile de fond des
tensions inter-religieuses exacerbée par
le break site
depuis plusieurs semaines la province
britannique a renoué avec les violences
urbaines entre protestants et
catholiques
waleed bin sauver les apparences
la première ministre nord-irlandaise en
déplacement dans une école primaire pour
fêter un anniversaire des plus spéciaux
lille fête ses 100 ans
un gâteau et une chorale un sourire
toutefois de circonstance mercredi 28
avril
arlene foster a posé sa démission un an
après sa prise de fonctions l'avenir de
l'irlande du nord plus que jamais en
suspens je suis entré pour la première
fois à l'assemblée en 2003 et le voyage
de ces 18 dernières années a sans aucun
doute été mémorable nous devons tous
apprendre à être généreux les uns envers
les autres à vivre ensemble et à
partager ce merveilleux pays
l'avenir de l'unionisme et de l'irlande
du nord ne se trouvera pas dans la
division
arlene foster défenseuse de
l'appartenance de l'irlande du nord au
royaume uni quittera la tête de son
parti unioniste démocrate le 28 mai et
son poste de premier ministre fin juin
une décision liée au futur conséquences
économiques du break site pour le pays
le break sites ayant ravivé les tensions
au sein même de l'irlande du nord en
paix depuis 1998 après un sanglant
conflit de trente ans en faisant 3500
morts unionistes protestants d'un côté
de l'autre républicains catholiques et
défenseurs plutôt d'une réunification
avec l'irlande
je pense qu'il y a plus affaire avec les
dirigeants politiques et les politiciens
c'est le type de mots qu'ils utilisent
qui répand la peur dans des communautés
comme celle ci les mécanismes exacts de
cette nouvelle frontières douanières en
mer d'irlande et les conséquences
exactes qui en découleraient n'ont
jamais été expliqués aux communautés
loyalistes d'irlande du nord
je pense qu'elles ont été quelque peu
choqué son moyrazès york la création
donc d'une nouvelle frontières
douanières en mer d'irlande au centre
des débats le break site désormais acté
après des semaines de négociations
l'irlande du nord est finalement resté
au sein du marché européen
ce qui signifie donc des futurs
contrôles douaniers et sanitaire entre
la provence britannique et le reste du
royaume uni une situation considérée
donc comme une trahison pour les nord
irlandais unionistes et amoureux de
l'union jack
toutes les générations sont en colère et
frustré par ce qui se passe ce satané
protocole est une invention européenne
et il est destiné à m'enlever mon
caractère britannique à proximité des
murs de paix à belfast mois d'avril 80
huit policiers ont été blessés au cours
de plusieurs nuits de violences mais
pour en parler nous sommes avec emilie
berthillot docteur est maître de
conférences en civilisation britannique
contemporaine université de lille
bonsoir et billy berclau merci d'être
avec nous alors c'est un centenaire on
l'aura compris très difficile à
commémorer certains fait ce qu'ils ont
gagné alors que les autres regrettent
toujours ce qu'ils ont perdu tout à fait
tout est fait pour parler un petit peu
de ces tensions il me semble important
de remonter au tout début l'acte d'union
qui avait été signé en 1801 et à partir
de cette date là l'irlande en fait est
unifié à la grande bretagne
et puis en fait c'est à partir de là que
les problèmes vont jean grenet vont être
puisque des groupes de punk de
dissidents politiques se forme tout au
long du xixème siècle pour demander
l'indépendance
ce qui débouche sur la guerre anglo
irlandaise de 1919 1921 et cette guerre
sans vaincu ni vainqueur se termine par
la signature le 6 décembre 1921 du
traité de londres qu'on appelle aussi
traité anglo irlandais qui coupent
l'irlande en deux donc l'irlande du sud
devient un état libre et obtiendra son
indépendance en 1949 et les six conti
d'irlande du nord quant à eux restent
accrochés au royaume est dit donc dans
ces comptes et vivent côte à côte des
nord-irlandais issues de la colonisation
venus des causes donc protestant avec
des nord-irlandais catholique et la
société nord-irlandaise devient petit à
petit une société qui offre des
privilèges aux protestants en ce qui
concerne notamment
l'accès à l'éducation aux emplois au
logement et petit à petit des tensions
de plus en plus vives se développe donc
comme la vidéo en faisait mention entre
1969 et 2009 une période de violences et
d'agitation politique aussi appelés les
troubles déchire les nord-irlandais et
les pertes s'élèvent à plus de 3500 3500
personnes donc d'un côté les protestants
pro-britanniques en faveur de la
partition surnommés les unionistes de
l'autre les catholiques nord-irlandais
le 6 avril nationaliste alors il faut
préciser que pardonnez-moi mais la mise
en oeuvre merci pour ce rappel
historique bien nécessaire à beaucoup
certainement d'entre nous la mise en
oeuvre du break site a ravivé donc les
tensions et l'irlande du nord est dans
l'union douanière de l'union européenne
les unionistes se sentent quoi trahi
aujourd'hui c'est de là que viennent ces
tensions tout à fait d'autant qu'en 2018
et 2019 le gouvernement britannique qui
était en pleines négociations avec
l'europe avait promis en fait de ne pas
de ne pas instaurer de contrôle douanier
donc la trahison est d'autant plus vive
que les le gouvernement britannique
n'avait pas du tout prévu ça au départ
lors de la signature du bric sic alors
il faut dire que le break s'y était
imposé une frontière de facto entre le
royaume uni et l'irlande du nord c'est
une situation qui est paradoxal pour les
unionistes
alors tout à fait puisque les unionistes
se sentent comme on l'a vu dans le
reportage britannique est donc
finalement c'est en fait comme si en
france on a en instaurait une frontière
à l'intérieur de la france donc
finalement la trahison ici et peut se
comprendre dans la mesure où leur propre
pays leur impose une frontière entre les
deux
clairement on a vu dans ces émeutes qui
ont éclaté depuis le 29 mars 1 est ce
que ces violences risquent de fragiliser
clairement la stabilité du pays
alors elle le risque oui tout à fait
puisque bon nous l'avons vu aussi dans
le reportage 90 officiers de police sont
blessés donc déjà sondé violence assez
bas qui crée en fait qui augmente le
nombre de morts et de pertes et surtout
qui ravive qui font revenir à la vie un
petit peu ce passé qui avait été qui
avait été au tour de notamment autour de
la question de l'identité qui avait été
un petit peu étouffé par les accords de
1998 et donc les problèmes resurgissent
et notamment parmi les jeunes qui se
font manipuler par des groupes
paramilitaires et des et des gangs
criminels en fait
merci emilie berthillot je rappelle que
vous êtes docteur 22 conférences en
civilisation britannique contemporaine à
l'université de lille merci d'avoir été
avec nous donc quelques instants la
première étape du déconfinement en
france aujourd'hui avec la reprise des
cours pour les collégiens et lycéens et
la fin des
les restrictions des 10 km et puis nous
évoquons également le vaccin espagnol
qui attend le feu vert des autorités
sanitaires d'ici la fin de l'année
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
monde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vtt pour tous ce que ça apporte aux
enfants c'est une confiance confiance en
soi ils ont soif d'apprendre et izm la
connaissance mais quelque chose les
blocs aussi dans l'apprentissage à
l'école les enfants de l'ambition ils
veulent à accéder à des gros poste
veulent s'évader du quartier qu'est ce
qui ne fonctionne pas dans
l'apprentissage à l'école les
professeurs les écoles fonds nécessaires
mais je rencontre des instituteurs des
institutrices en ce1 ce2 il ya des
enfants qui ont vraiment encore du mal à
lire et écrire
et c'est pénalisant pour l'enfant pour
leurs familles on oublie les parents qui
sont responsables du foyer est temps que
les parents ne maîtrise et ne parlent
pas le français à la maison bassa d'être
difficile
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple sap
est une volonté collectés vous le savez
pour moi qui dès qu'on dit il n'y a pas
d'alternative en sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu livrant une forme c'est quand même
des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas la double hic
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté zulu
remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
en avril aura lieu le 60e anniversaire
du vol de youri gagarine en ayant eu la
chance de m'entraîner avec nos collègues
russes j'ai vraiment plongé dans une
atmosphère où j'ai vécu auprès de méroé
gagarine était présent à chaque point de
bâtiments de salles de sport de place de
la cité des étoiles moi je crois
beaucoup dans la diplomatie scientifique
et quand vous parlez de la coopération
scientifique sur la station bihan ou la
station spatiale internationale
c'est une forme de diplomatie on a très
peu d'objets aujourd'hui qui peuvent
être des outils diplomatiques aussi aux
six ans
[Musique]
les accords d'abraham change l'équilibré
stratégique pour le moyen-orient après
50 ans d'immobilisme dans cette région
complexe tron était le seul à pouvoir
créer les conditions d'une paix durable
grâce à ses relations différentes avec
tous les acteurs
le problème est maintenant de voir
comment joe biden va traiter un sujet
s'il relance l'accord actuel des accords
d'abraham resteront une alliance
stratégique contre l'iran qui unira les
pays de la région et réglera les
relations avec israël
l'europe se cantonne dans le rôle de
spectateur sceptiques en ayant
totalement minimiser la dynamique créée
par les accords de bras si tout se
déroule comme l'envisageait donald trump
et ses négociateurs 2020 n'aura pas été
seulement l'année de lakovic 19 elle
sera aussi celle des accords de bâle
[Musique]
21h merci nous rejoindre en direct sur
rt france pour cette deuxième heure
d'émission tout de suite voici les
titres de l'actualité de ce lundi 3 mai
première étape aujourd'hui du
déconfinement progressif en france avec
la reprise des cours en présentiel pour
les collégiens et lycéens mais également
la fin des limites des 10 km depuis son
domicile le couvre feu lui toujours
maintenu à 19h côté vaccination
le régulateur européen des buts
l'évaluation de celui de fighter by one
tech pour les 12 15 ans l'espagne qui
avait déjà allégé ces restrictions
souhaite lancer son propre vaccin d'ici
la fin de l'année le labo hypra enquête
elle travaille depuis un an la
conception d'un nouveau vaccin pour
l'humain contre locaux vides alors que
les étapes de la recherche et de la
conception sont désormais terminées la
firme espère un feu vert européen en
octobre
les actionnaires ont le sourire les
grandes entreprises françaises cotées
devrait leur verser quelques 52
milliards d'euros de dividendes cette
année soit un rebond de 42 % en un an
concernant les résultats de l'année 2020
et ce en dépit de la crise
pour rappel l'année dernière des
dividendes avaient baissé de 45%
[Musique]
un quartier parisien en proie depuis
deux nuits des tirs de mortier visant
les trafiquants de drogue les scènes se
déroulent avenue de flandre dans le
19ème arrondissement
en dépit d'un plan crack mise en place
en septembre 2010 par les autorités les
riverains sont exaspérés par ces
attroupements de personnes liées à la
vente ou à la consommer sur le drogue
un phénomène qui dure depuis des années
[Musique]
depuis ce matin les collégiens et
lycéens étudie donc à nouveau en
présentiel c'est aussi la fin de la
limite des 10 km le couvre feu lui
toujours maintenu à 19h coup d'envoi
donc ce lundi de la première des quatre
étapes de confinement progressif liées à
la crise sanitaire
on fait le point avec antoine logié un
lundi porteur d'espoir dans les rues de
la capitale
un mois après le 3e confinement a posées
par le gouvernement pour lutter contre
la propagation du colis de 19 le pays
entame une nouvelle phase de
déconfinement pas de levée complète des
restrictions annoncées à ce jour mais
une sortie de crise espéré est envisagée
en quatre étapes
ce lundi les déplacements inter
régionaux en france sont de nouveau
autorisées et il n'est plus nécessaire
de présenter une attestation pour les
déplacements en journée les cours en
présentiel reprennent dès ce jour pour
les collégiens et lycéens mais le nombre
d'élèves par classe restent limités et
si le couvre feu est maintenu le
gouvernement nous gratifie tout de même
d'une nouvelle attestation indispensable
pour les déplacements compris entre 19
heures et 6 heures du matin il faudra
donc attendre jusqu'au 19 mai pour
profiter plus longuement des soirées
c'est en effet à cette date que marquera
le début de la deuxième étape du
déconfinement avec des changements plus
importants cette fois le gouvernement
prévoit de décaler le couvre-feu à 21h
les magasins pourront rouvrir tout comme
les terrasses des restaurants restées
closes depuis le début du décret du 29
octobre 2020 dans les lieux culturels
que sont les cinémas les théâtres ou
encore les musées seront eux aussi
autorisé à rouvrir à condition de
respecter les protocoles sanitaires
réouverture également des établissements
sportifs pour les spectateurs avec une
limite de 800 personnes en intérieur et
1000 en extérieur autre changement
majeur à partir de cette date la reprise
de certaines activités sportives
couvertes et en plein air dans le
respect des protocoles sanitaires
si le couvre-feu est raccourcie de
quelques heures il sera autorisé à
partir du 19 mai de se réunir non pas à
6 mai à 10 personnes
la troisième étape du déconfinement aura
lieu le 9 juin prochain
le couvre feu sera alors décalé à 23h
les salles des cafés des restaurants
succéderont aux terrasses et pourront
ouvrir en acceptant maximum six
personnes par table
jusqu'à 5000 personnes pourront se
réunir dans des lieux accueillant du
public et la pratique d'activités
sportives s'élargira aux sports de
contact autre changement important
l'accueil de touristes étrangers
présentant un pass sanitaires à savoir
un test pcr ou une attestation de
vaccination enfin la quatrième et
dernière date de ce calendrier à savoir
le 30 juin 2021 marquera l'étape la plus
importante de ceux des confinement sans
pour autant signifier un retour complet
à la vie normale
cette fois le couvre-feu ne sera plus en
vigueur et en possession n'a pas
sanitaires il sera autorisé de
participer à tout type d'événement
réunissant plus de 1000 personnes
malgré ces nombreux changements
réjouissant tous seront cependant soumis
à l'évolution de la situation sanitaire
et il n'est pas exclu de voir ces
mesures s'adapter en fonction de la
situation dans les territoires
grande absente de ces nouvelles mesures
les discothèques qui reste fermé jusqu'à
nouvel ordre est la levée progressive
des restrictions repose aussi plus que
jamais sur la campagne de vaccination
qui est censé s'accélérer sur tout le
territoire mais où en est la vaccination
aujourd'hui en france éléments de
réponse avec florian lambert alors que
la levée des restrictions s'appliquent
progressivement en quatre étapes sur
tout le territoire les français se
préparent à la fameuse vie d'après mais
où en est-on concrètement concernant la
vaccination contre le coc vite 19 en
france selon les chiffres officiels de
ce lundi 15 millions sept cent mille
français ont reçu une première dose soit
un quart de la population
un chiffre qui pourrait sembler
encourageant mais seuls 6 million et
demi d'entre eux soit 10% de la
population se sont vu injecter la
deuxième dose synonyme d'immunisation
contre le kobe 19 mai la campagne
vaccinale devraient s'accélérer
de très nombreuses quantités de vaccins
vont être livrés prochainement sur le
sol français
2 5 millions de doses faiseur et dans le
même temps les prises de rendez vous ont
explosé ces derniers jours sur la
plateforme d'octo lives 55% de prise de
rendez-vous supplémentaires ont été
enregistrées ces derniers jours au total
1,2 million de français ont pris leurs
rendez vous a révélé la plateforme
souhaitant un retour à une vie normale
le plus rapidement possible certaines
régions se sont organisés à leur manière
en haute corse à bastia des adultes de
18 à 55 ans ont pu recevoir leur
première dose dès la fin du mois d'avril
cela faisait trois semaines que nous
mûrissons la décision quand nous voyons
que nous avions de plus en plus de
créneaux et que nos objectifs étaient
atteints concernant la population la
plus âgée puisque 83% des 70-75 ans et
résidant encore sont vaccinés à ce
rythme l'objectif annoncé par emmanuel
macron fin mars de 30 millions de
premières doses administrées d'ici la mi
juin reste plausible au total
aujourd'hui 10% de la population
française est vacciné et pour en parler
nous sommes avec philippe froguel
généticien professeur à l'impérial
college de londres et à l'université
lille ii bonsoir les programmes merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous en direct sur
arte france alors plutôt que d'élargir à
tous les plus de 50 ans sans distinction
le gouvernement on l'a compris cible
toujours les plus fragiles a élargi sa
campagne de vaccination à d'autres
populations est ce que c'est la bonne
décision pour vous il fallait
accélérer le rythme de cette manière
c'est une décision qui est logique
puisque ce sont les personnes qui sont
plus à risque de se retrouver à
l'hôpital ou de mourir
cela dit ce ne sont pas ces personnes
qui transmettent le plus le virus et
plus des gens plus jeunes et actifs et
donc ce qu'on voit un peu partout en
réalité ces profils et c'est que le ceux
qui ont envie de se faire vacciner
peuvent peuvent y aller
et donc c'est commencent à arriver
partout et je pense que finalement c'est
pas si mal que ça la seule limite
aujourd'hui c'est nombre de doses
vaccinales qui sont disponibles ça va
être quand même très très très dur
fin juin arriver à faire 30 millions de
personnes on a quand même deux mois deux
au moins de repères par rapport à
l'angleterre
la vie c'est plutôt je vais y arriver le
gouvernement qui vise une immunité
collectif 1 août
ça me semble possible c'est une unité
collective est un mythe
en réalité puisque avec le nouveau
nouveau variant où les nouveaux variants
il faut avoir à peu près 80% de la
population
immunisé pour l'éviter voire plus et
donc on n'arrivera pas à ça à ce moment
là donc il falloir se préparer à vivre
encore avec le virus en en l'automne à
faire peut-être d'autres types de
vaccination troisième in troisième dose
et a continué à faire attention
justement vous parlez des variants vous
êtes très en pointe sur les techniques
de séquençage est ce qu'on commence à en
savoir davantage sur ces différents
variant dont on parle souvent l'indien
le brésilien qui font si peur
alors nous dans les hauts de france
on étudie systématiquement mais de
manière aléatoire des préventes ont été
positifs en laboratoire de ville pour
l'instant on n'a trouvé ni indien et on
a plus de brasilia
on a quelques sud africain la situation
n'est pas trop mauvaise
le variés anglais commençent à muter on
ne sait pas trop ce que ça veut dire
mais bon pour l'instant c'est plutôt
rassurant mais on a vu que on a laissé
entrer en france début avril des
personnes d'inde et qui sont atteints
par ce variant et ya peu qu à espérer
que ça restera dans certains endroits et
que ça va pas disséminés quand on nous
dit souvent ici ou là ces variants sont
plus dangereux plus meurtrier même est
ce que vous vous le constatez honda on a
vraiment l'impression que dans les états
où il ya le plus de ce variant d'y
indien et bien c'est là où il ya plus de
cas est le plus de plus de mort et moi
j'ai souvenir de nous marier anglais les
gens disent ah mais non mais non il n'ya
pas plus dangereux et puis on s'est bien
aperçu quand on va éditer il l'était
tout comme le sud africain
il a un peu la sélection naturelle
ces virus s'adapte et plus on aura une
circulation importante en france et plus
on tarde à on parlera finir à la
vaccination et on risque de se retrouver
avec une situation compliquée avec et
des variants activeront on à la sortie
de crise plus difficile philippe regarde
ça veut dire que nécessairement les
variants sont de plus en plus dangereux
à chaque fois on pas forcément pas
forcément mais ce qu'on constate
aujourd'hui surtout dans les sociétés
qui se vaccinent c'est que ce sont ceux
qui résistent le plus à la vaccination
ils se transmettent le plus qui est qui
survivent et il ya des variants qui sont
moins dangereux mais on les a pas
vraiment étudié et c'est un peu dommage
parce que c'était une des solutions
aussi à voir avec des virus très beaux
actifs
on laisse se développer ce qui permet
d'avoir une nuit
et collectif qui fonctionne mais c'est
pas ce qui s'est passé là jusqu'à
présent alors alors qu'un quart de la
population a été vaccinée pour l'instant
en france un de la première dose
le vaccin fader a été étudié pour les 12
15 ans est la suite logique il faut
aller le plus vite possible sur sur ce
plan c'est le début des des solutions
les adolescents sont peu malade mais son
transmetteur très important du virus à
leurs parents à leurs grands parents
partout et donc à partir du moment où on
va difficilement arriver à cette
immunité dite collective avant la fin de
l'été et probablement après la seule
solution sera de vacciner les
adolescents ont vraiment essayer
d'éradiquer cette pandémie
merci philippe regarde généticien
professeur à l'impérial collège de
londres et de l'université lille ii
d'avoir été avec nous et nous apporter
votre analyse sur la vaccination à ce
jour merci à vous et direction l'espagne
à présent le pays espère lancer son
vaccin anti copie d'ici la fin de
l'année un laboratoire en catalogne
travaille actuellement sur sa conception
bonsoir les crises
là vous êtes correspondante en espagne
pour rt france c'est un projet très
attendu relie majine dans le pays
le laboratoire pharmaceutique hypra qui
donc situé dans la province de gérone en
catalogne qui travaillent sur ce vaccin
cette entreprise familiale d'un peu plus
de 2000 salariés est spécialisée depuis
le début des années 70 dans la
fabrication de vaccins pour animaux
mais depuis la pandémie elle s'est
proposé de collaborer notamment en
fabriquant un premier test sérologique
il désormais en travaillant sur un
vaccin contre le coronavirus alors elle
veut mettre à profit sa grande
expérience car elle explique que le
travail reste le même que ce soit pour
un accès pour les animaux ou pour
l'homme alors lors d'une visite dans le
laboratoire le premier ministre espagnol
pedro sanchez a déclaré je cite c'est un
projet prometteur nous voulons dire que
le gouvernement parie sur vous sur
l'espoir que nous avons de compter sur
un accent espagnol en 2021
alors concrètement hypra travaille sur
deux projets de vaccins suivi par l'
agence espagnole médicaments alors un
premier pourra se conserver entre 2 et 8
degrés et en second devra être conservé
dans des congélateurs alors à l'heure
actuelle il faudrait deux doses pour
chaque versant mais les chercheurs
n'écarte pas l'hypothèse de changer ce
vaccin en fonction des nouveaux variants
mais aussi des résultats des essais
cliniques
alors concrètement quand les espagnols
pourront ils disposent et de se sert à
200 400 millions c'est l'objectif de
donna produire donc au cours de l'année
2022 et pour 2023 il serait possible de
produire jusqu'à 1 milliard de doses de
l'entreprise repose sur un modèle
d'organisation visant à contrôler en
interne tout le processus de la chaîne
alors c'est à dire qu'elle est la seule
et l'unique pour la recherche la
production et la commercialisation des
vaccins alors pour ce faire il prat
souhaite doubler la taille de son siège
et acquérir de nouveaux terrains afin
d'assurer cette grande production
alors les résultats sont déjà très
satisfaisant et elle espère donc
recevoir le feu vert dans l'année car si
tout va bien l'essai clinique pourra
débuter dès juin sur l'homme alors
l'objectif est de voir quelle dose va
générer le plus
anticor et donc les responsables du
projet disent déjà être pouvoir proposer
des vaccins efficaces et donc ça
permettrait de lancer la production au
mois d'octobre
une fois la validation obtenu par toutes
les autorités compétentes
merci si leslie c'est une gare en direct
de barcelone merci à vous et pour en
parler nous sommes avec philippe
emmanueli médecins français exerçant en
espagne bonsoir fou d'emmanuelli merci
d'être avec nous l'espagnol vient de
voir qu'ils espèrent donc entrer dans le
cercle très réservé en des pays
producteurs de vaccins on imagine qu'en
tant que médecin vous n'attendais que ça
oui l'espagne ne bouderai pas son
plaisir à rentrer dans la cour des
grands qui disposent de leurs propres
vaccins et là on pense évidemment à l'
aventure de valve déjà en france qui
n'avait pas retenu l'attention des
pouvoirs publics dès le début et qui
était tombé dans le giron anglais et
bien l'espagne ne veut surtout pas
aujourd'hui suivre l'exemple de valve
neva et suit de très près effectivement
cet espoir que donne aujourd'hui le
laboratoire libre à quelle fiabilité
peut-on accorder à ce laboratoire dont
qui développe habituellement des vaccins
pour les animaux alors écoutez d'abord
il faut il faut rappeler que l'épidémie
du coronavirus correspond à ce qu'on
appelle une zoonose une entrepose rose
c'est à dire une maladie animale à
transmission humaine et c'est vrai que
dans ce cadre les laboratoires de santé
animale présente un intérêt tout
particulier je rappeler dans ce cadre
effectivement que par exemple en france
meirieu est le deuxième laboratoire
mondial de santé animale et contribue
fortement au développement de solutions
en santé humaine et vous savez c'est
quelque chose qui est relativement
récent qui a été repris au niveau
mondial par effectivement cette notion
de one health c'est à dire une santé
unique pour les animaux les êtres
humains et l'environnement
donc c'est vrai que oui je vous en prie
donc c'est vrai que l'idée qu'à raqqa
laboratoire de santé animale puisse
participer et puissent contribuer à
l'élaboration
un vaccin pour la santé humaine est loin
d'être farfelue
alors il pourrait s'agir du premier
vaccin anti qu'ovide entièrement conçu
et fabriqué en europe c'est un défi
scientifique mais on imagine aussi
économique face aux deux géants au géant
pfizer
oui effectivement c'est un c'est un
énorme défi économique surtout que ibra
n'est quand même pas un gros laboratoire
même si c'est vrai qu'il représente
environ 200 millions de chiffre
d'affaires par an mais aujourd'hui il a
le soutien de l'état espagnol et c'est
ce qui peut lui permettre d'espérer de
mener à bien à la fois les études
nécessaires pour prouver l'innocuité et
l'efficacité des vaccins et pour ensuite
envisager la commercialisation de ce
vaccin
alors philippe emmanuel dit il s'agit
d'un vaccin dit classique c'est-à-dire
qu'il contient le virus atténué ducobu
de 19 il est comparable aujourd'hui à
quel vaccin
oui alors non justement les deux
forme de vaccins qui sont retenus par
hypra sont les deux mêmes formes de
vaccins que sanofi en france c'est à
dire d'une part une protéine
recombinante
en gros c'est un morceau de virus mais
artificielle qui est reproduit qui
permet de générer des anticorps contre
cette protéine qui effectivement est un
morceau de virus mais par contre ça
n'est pas un virus
ça n'est pas un vaccin à virus vivant
atténué ça n'est pas non plus un vaccin
adénovirus comme celui d'astrazeneca et
donc il ya ce premier vaccin à protéines
recombinantes et il y a également un
deuxième vaccin qui est celui à arn
messagers également donc ça veut dire a
priori que les problèmes qu'il a eus
autour d'astra zeneca notamment et
johnson & johnson ne vont pas se
retrouver sur ce vaccin dipra oui
exactement
les pistes effectivement de vaccins sur
le modèle de l'année dans virus ont été
écartés et on se retrouve effectivement
quelque sorte avec les finalistes dans
la course au vaccin qui pour le moment
donne les meilleurs résultats en termes
de sécurité d'emploi comment gères le
gouvernement ce dossier vaccinale est ce
qu'il est déjà prévu que cela soit
redistribuée dans toute l'europe comme
ça c'est fait d'ailleurs avec les
aliments bio ntech qui n'ont pas gardé
plus de vaccins pour eux mais ont dû
alors et partir sur tout le territoire
européen ce que c'est la même chose des
bons moments il n'y a pas de stratégie
dans la mesure où les études ne sont pas
encore suffisamment avancé mais ce qui
est certain c'est qu'effectivement il ya
une vraie volonté d'aboutir dans la
fabrication de ces vaccins et qu'en cas
de succès des études et bien
effectivement de telles stratégies
seront à l'ordre du jour une dernière
petite question sur la situation
sanitaire en espagne comment les choses
se passent en espagne aujourd'hui
l'évolution est favorable le les
couvre-feux maintenant on est et vont
être levés
le leurre de couvre-feu a été notamment
élargi en catalogne
donc on est toujours dans ce retour
progressif à la normale dans de bonnes
conditions mais avec une vigilance
toujours particulière sur les
indicateurs épidémiologique
comme tout le monde on n'aura pas merci
philippe emmanuel y avait un français
exerçant en espagne d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france est
toujours en espagne j - avant des
élections régionales cruciales demain
dans la communauté de madrid un scrutin
à la portée nationale qui pourrait
sanctionner le gouvernement socialiste
de pedro sanchez
décryptage de guémar aussi ce mardi en
espagne tous les regards seront braqués
sur la capitale et pour cause le vote
qui doit renouveler l'assemblée
législative de la communauté autonome de
madrid a tout du scrutin explosif
d'abord parce que la région est la plus
riche du pays qu'elle représente 20% du
pib et qu'elle est dotée de pouvoirs
considérables ensuite parce que madrid
et sa région dirigée par la droite et
épicentre de la première vague de la
pandémie de covile 19 se sont opposés au
gouvernement central sur la crise
sanitaire
preuve des enjeux que revêt ce vote la
présence du premier ministre pedro
sanchez à la tribune aux côtés du
candidat socialiste
madrid ne peut pas continuer à être
divisé à ne peut pas continuer à être
systématiquement en conflit avec le
gouvernement espagnol et avec les
gouvernements régionaux voisins qu'ils
appartiennent au parti populaire ou au
parti socialiste le chef du gouvernement
c'est que son parti est en mauvaise
posture dans la capitale car la favorite
des sondages c'est elle isabelle diaz
ayuso la présidente de la communauté de
madrid à la chef de l'exécutif de la
région
cette figure montante du parti populaire
le principal parti d'opposition de
droite a fait campagne sur une critique
de la gestion de la pandémie par le
gouvernement central la jeune femme a
d'ailleurs fait de la communauté de
madrid la région de la plus permissive
du pays
en maintenant bars restaurants cinémas
et théâtres ouvert ils m'ont dit tu dois
fermer
tu dois fermer parce que le ministre le
dit et j'ai dit au président du
gouvernement je ne vais pas fermé madrid
parce qu'il n'y a aucune raison pour le
caylar union parce que le vote unis du
parti populaire est le seul vaccin
efficace contre le centrisme contre ce
radicalisme contre la ruine contre la
confrontation dans les rues pourtant
bien qu actuellement crédité de 40 % des
intentions de vote
isabelle diaz ayuso ne pourra sans doute
pas gouverner seul et devra donc
s'allier à vox la formation nationaliste
qui soutient déjà le parti populaire à
la mairie de madrid et dans deux autres
régions les membres de vox ne cache pas
une certaine nostalgie pour le
franquisme
ce qui leur vaut d'être taxé de
fascistes par les radicaux de gauche de
podemos également lancer dans la course
les rouges contre les fascistes le vieil
antagonistes fantômes de la dictature
espagnole s'est même concrétisé durant
la campagne par l'envoi de lettres
contenant des balles des menaces de mort
dont deux ont été adressées à des
candidats dans quelques instants nous
parlerons des dividendes versés aux
actionnaires d'entreprises françaises +
42 % en un an malgré la crise sanitaire
et puis nous parlerons des heurts entre
des riverains excédés les trafiquants de
drogue
la tension monte dans le quartier de
stalingrad à paris vous entendrez le
témoignage d'un riverain notamment
[Musique]
le théâtre du châtel c'est par un
théâtre comme les autres c'est un
théâtre qui est très diversifiée dans un
programmation de la culture est une
activité absolument essentiel de notre
société de sa cohésion de sa cohérence
c'est aussi le rôle du châtelet de
pouvoir mettre en contact des très
belles productions avec le public
qu'est ce qu'on fait dans un théâtre en
plein confinement on a essayé de
réinventer notre métier et en
particulier on a fait beaucoup de
travail avec la télévision on a permis
de capter à 50 de spectacle pour la
télévision ce qui est une autre manière
de pouvoir créer la relation avec le
public je suis sûr qu'il y aura une
grande volonté du public de revenir dans
les théâtres
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple sap
est une volonté collectés vous le savez
pour moi qui dès qu'on dit il n'y a pas
d'alternative au sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers l'uniforme c'est quand
même des hommes comment ces mecs-là
arrive à dormir la nuit là aussi je
pense qu'on a vécu quelque chose d'inouï
gilet jaune c'était des valeurs de
droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas l'oubli
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il ya quand même la liberté je vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
vous êtes renversé par un homme de 92
ans qui perd le contrôle de son véhicule
deux ans et demi plus tard vous vous
imposez comme un espoir français du
tennis fauteuil objectif est les jeux
paralympiques de paris est vrai que le
sport m'a toujours sauver le tennis
c'est que c'est mon sport
bon il ya un fauteuil mais je vais
essayer et en fait je me suis rendu
compte que ça allait c'était
suffisamment physique pour moi j'ai une
vie de sportif de haut niveau je
m'entraîne tous les jours c'est devenu
ma vie la raison de me lever le matin
j'avais toujours ce vieux rêve de petite
fille de faire du sport de ma vie est
finalement là c'est ce que je réalise
avec le jambon c'est un autre combat on
ma vie qui est celui de la sécurité
routière s'agit d'un projet de loi qui
vise à mettre en place des tests
d'aptitude pour tous les conducteurs pas
seulement les seniors on a un contrôle
technique de son véhicule
il faut un contrôle technique de sa
personne et sa l'état doit re doit
imposer loi sur ce sujet là
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
un certain regain de confiance est rompu
entre le politique et les experts même
les citoyens on est une société qui est
totalement percuté et on ne peut pas
considérer une démocratie vit
véritablement l'amplitude de ses
possibles et l'amplitude de ses valeurs
quand elle est à ce point confiné est-ce
que vous avez le sentiment on repart à
zéro par rapport à l'année dernière
la société ne survivra pas à une
succession de confinement une société
c'est pas de confinement
c'est la liberté c'est la créativité
c'est le sentiment d'exister
d'appartenir
comment on va réorganiser le monde il
est vrai que la pandémie c'est vivre
[Musique]
les accords d'abraham change les
équilibres stratégiques pour le
moyen-orient après 50 ans d'immobilisme
dans cette région complexe tron était le
seul à pouvoir créer les conditions
d'une paix durable grâce à ses relations
différentes avec tous les acteurs
le problème est maintenant de voir
comment joe biden va traiter un sujet
s'il relance l'accord actuel des accords
d'abraham resteront une alliance
stratégique contre l'iran tu n'iras les
pays de la région et réglera les
relations avec israël
l'europe se cantonne dans le rôle de
spectateur sceptiques en ayant
totalement minimiser la dynamique créée
par les accords de bras si tout se
déroule comme l'envisageait donald trump
et ses négociateurs 2020 n'aura pas été
seulement l'année de lakovic 19
elle sera aussi celle des accords de
branche
[Musique]
21h03 ans ou et les bienvenus en direct
sur rtl france si vous nous rejoignez
après plus d'un an de crise les plans
sociaux explosent les défaillances chute
les licenciements se multiplient et
pourtant les actionnaires devraient
recevoir pas moins de 52 milliards
d'euros de dividendes pour l'année 2000
21 bassins chebbi dans un pays
économiquement en berne voguant rythme
des licenciements et des plans sociaux
les grandes entreprises françaises ne
semble plus être à la diète 52 milliards
d'euros c'est la coquette somme que vont
pouvoir se partager les actionnaires des
groupes du cac 40
selon l'entreprise d'informations
économiques et hs marquis qu un rebond
de 42 % en un an réalisée sur les
chiffres d'affaires de l'année 2020
cette même année qui a été rythmée par
des licenciements massifs et des plans
sociaux sur l'ensemble du pays
en tête deux podiums le géant pétrolier
total qui va pouvoir généreusement
gratifié ses actionnaires de la modique
somme de 7 milliards d'euros loin devant
bnp paribas avec ses 4 milliards d'euros
ou encore axa et ses quelques 3,5
milliards d'euros
mais si cette pratique fondamentale du
capitalisme a toujours fait partie du
paysage économique
c'est bel et bien le contexte sanitaire
économique et social dans lequel elle
est opérée qui fait débat
certaines de ces entreprises ont
bénéficié pour faire face à la crise du
colis de prêts garantis par l'état ont
eu recours au chômage partiel des
ajustements qui les ont conduits en
contrepartie à baisser leurs dividendes
l'année dernière une baisse largement
compensé en 2021
une pratique qui n'est pas au goût de
tout le monde l'observatoire des
multinationales très critique envers les
entreprises du cac40 dénonce cette
générosité les grandes entreprises
continuent à toucher des aides publiques
massives chômage partiel plomb d'urgence
plan de relance soutien de la bce et
cetera auxquels devraient s'ajouter
bientôt les sommes issues de plans de
relance européens le reste de l'économie
pme petits commerces services publics
secteur culturel et non lucratif reste
enfoncée dans la crise alors que la
quiétude sociale grandit et que les
français sont de plus en plus nombreux à
battre le pavé pour sauver leurs emplois
le baromètre du partage du profit les
res a révélé que seuls 39 % de ces
grandes entreprises ont décidé d'annuler
le versement des dividendes pour 2020 et
pour en parler nous sommes ce avec un
philippe béchade rédacteur en chef de la
bourse au quotidien président d
econoclaste bonsoir l'idée chad merci
d'être avec nous un rebond dont 2 42% 5
pour les résultats de 2020 année plombée
importants par la crise sanitaire
évidemment comment on s'explique cela
c'est la question tout le monde se pose
on a un rebond de 42% après une chute de
- 45
donc je veux dire qu'on n'est pas encore
revenu au niveau de 10 dans de
distribuer fin 2019 début 2020 ou les
hypothèses à l'époque c'était plutôt
autour de 2 70 75
milliards de dividendes j'entendais donc
total allait distribuer généreusement 7
milliards je dirais que c'est un
dividende inchangé pour l'instant pour
l'année 2000 21
alors je dis pas qu'il aura pas
peut-être un petit quelque chose
un reliquat en décembre enfin pour
l'instant on n'annonce pas chez total
par exemple de forte hausse du dividende
pour les banques
il ya eu donc une année une année sans
et on va avoir une reprise du versement
des dividendes sur des niveaux de
profitabilité qui pour l'instant n'ont
pas retrouvé non plus les niveaux de fin
des bulles 2020 alors est-ce que c'est
choquant que les entreprises versent des
dividendes à mon sens non parce que
c'est le jeu du capitalisme
après évidemment si l'entreprise se sert
de l'argent avancé par l'état pour
récompenser les actionnaires là
effectivement on pouvait on peut ouvrir
de grands yeux
pour l'instant je dirais qu'il ya pas
encore de cas vraiment choquant je sais
par exemple que danone a exercé un le
pge qui sera ensuite remboursés j'irais
pas jusqu'a les accusés de se servir de
ces sommes pour verser un dividende aux
actionnaires d'ailleurs on a beaucoup à
reprocher d'ailleurs à danone de ne pas
être assez généreux et ce qui a coûté
récemment sa tête à son à son président
ça n'explique pas comment est possible
ce rebond de 42% alors qu'on nous dit
qu'il ya une crise sanitaire majeure
comment cela se fait-il que les
résultats aient autant bondi cette année
selon vous alors les résultats les plus
spectaculaires
on les a observés dans le secteur du
luxe
le luxe est absolument inoxydable on le
voit bien que le monde soit en crise ou
pas le luxe progresse toujours
il ya eu un tout petit passage à vide
l'année dernière premiers débuts
deuxième trimestre parce que les chinois
étaient étaient moins présents
et puis les géants du luxe ont très bien
rebondi en recourant massivement
aux ventes en ligne s'il s'était
contenté effectivement d'attendre que
les touristes chinois reviennent dans
les aéroports sur les champs elysées
oxford street où la 5e avenue il serait
il fait grise mine donc les ventes ont
très très fortement progressé aussi bien
pour lvmh et toutes ces marques que pour
kering c'est-à-dire gucci
on a vu le même phénomène d'ailleurs
même pour pour tiffany qui appartient
maintenant également à lvmh en fait tous
les groupes du luxe ont magnifiquement
performé durant toute l'année 2020 je ne
sais pas si les asiatiques pour conjurer
cette période pénible ont renforcé leurs
achats d'articles de luxe en tout cas
dans les chiffres d'affaires c'est assez
spectaculaire
je vois par exemple que pour lvmh
dans le secteur de la maroquinerie
joaillerie et l'horlogerie
ils font plus 50 + 50 % et des profits
absolument record donc n'oublions pas
que les entreprises du cac 40 sont
d'abord des multinationales et que la
france est typiquement dans l'excès dans
l'exemple du secteur du luxe
la france ne représente que 15 ou 20 %
de leur chiffre d'affaires
et je dirais que au niveau marge les
meilleures marges elles sont elles sont
fait effectivement avec la clientèle
asiatique
si on reparle des banques que quelques
secondes l'année 2020 n'a pas été
catastrophique puisqu'il ya en fait il
ya eu très peu de faillite ce qui les
aurait peut-être obligé à augmenter
leurs provisions pour pertes
on voit que ça n'a pas été le cas grâce
aux aides aux états unis il ya eu
beaucoup moins dead et pourtant on voit
également que les les banques
retire par centaines de millions voire
par milliards leurs provisions donc ça
augmente mécaniquement le résultat alors
résultat distribuable ou pas en tout cas
les banques pour l'instant se porte bien
la plupart des secteurs se portent très
bien et la seule déception finalement au
sein du cac 40 c'est atos
c'est à peu près là le seul exemple une
entreprise ou vraiment ça va moins bien
aujourd'hui que ça n'allait fin 2020 ou
au printemps 2020 ça se passe bien
non non rien et moi pardonnez moi on
nous promet une crise économique majeure
à l'issue de cette crise sanitaire ça
veut dire que ces chiffres là sont quand
même plutôt encourageant ou au
finalement ça concerne qu'une partie des
des entreprises ça ne veut pas dire
grand chose
il faut vraiment faire la différence
entre une multinationale
donc c'est à dire toutes les valeurs du
cac 40 la plupart des valeurs du sbf 120
dont les marchés se font majoritairement
à l'étranger et cette année on anticipe
une reprise de six et demi pour cent à
l'échelle planétaire
donc il faut vraiment clairement
distingués des entreprises qui font du
chiffre d'affaires en asie aux états
unis et des entreprises franco
françaises qui ont une zone de
chalandise local régional voire
peut-être nationale lorsque les aides
les pg e vont tous ces aides vont être
progressivement levées les problèmes
vont apparaître là jusqu'à présent les
entreprises peuvent repousser jusqu'à
maintenant à avril 2022
le remboursement des prêts et c'est
simplement repoussé mais quel sera le
chiffre d'affaires de pme pmi françaises
même d'ici l'automne si la saison
estivale par exemple les ratés dans
l'hôtellerie la restauration
donc je fais vraiment clair la
différence entre des entreprises qui ont
une exposition au marché domestique et
des entreprises qui ont une exposition
internationale qui vit qui versent des
dividendes à des actionnaires des fonds
de retraite internationaux et en france
vous voyez la plupart des banquiers qui
aujourd'hui constate qu on a 150
milliards 180 milliards d' épargne les
gens qu on l épargne vous entendez tous
les conseillers bancaires assureurs vie
vous dire fait des actions allaient vers
la bourse il ya des dividendes et vous
avez des tas de fonds de retraite pour
qui
leur survie dépend aussi du fait que les
entreprises versent des dividendes donc
il ya à mon avis rien de choquant par
contre je voulais rajouter quelque chose
on fait beaucoup beaucoup actuellement
de débat autour ses dividendes
mais quelque chose de discret et qui
rapporte autant aux actionnaires je vous
assure je là je suis très très sérieux
ce sont les rachats de titres
certes les entreprises dans une période
de crise on pourrait se dire ils doivent
être un petit peu à court de cash où ils
doivent peut-être attendre les plans de
relance pour participer à l'effort de
transition énergétique verdissement de
la planète est en fait vous apercevez
qu'il ya des beaucoup d'entreprises qui
ont des excès de cash et qui en profite
pour racheter leurs propres titres
et là je ne vous parle pas d'un
phénomène marginal puisque en france on
parle du versement de 50 2 milliards de
dividendes mais aux états unis pour 2021
n'anticipe plus de 500 ou 510 milliards
de dividendes versés et bien figurez
vous que les plans de rachats de titres
c'est à dire de la valeur restituer aux
actionnaires on attend entre 530 et 550
milliards
donc ils vont être versés aux
actionnaires se sont pas des dividendes
mais ça va quand même tombés dans leurs
poches et ça se compare à 838 150
milliards il y a deux ans c'est à dire
juste avant la crise
donc les dividendes c'est une chose mais
n'oublions pas également cette pratique
des rachats de titres et d'y contribuer
également à restituer beaucoup de valeur
aux actionnaires
apple par exemple a annoncé 90 milliards
de rachats de titres apple a réalisé un
bénéfice de 23 milliards
il va en disent ils vont distribuer une
partie mais c'est rien à côté des 90
milliards de rachats de titres c'est
surtout ça qui va profiter par exemple
aux actionnaires américains
en france les bars achats de titres ça
reste quelque chose encore assez
marginal actuellement qu'est ce qu'on a
comme plan a annoncé on arcelormittal ou
carrefours autour de 500 millions
donc vous voyez l'échelle est pas tout à
fait la même messi
l'économie redémarre vous verrez
également que les rachats de titres vont
un moment venir talonner les dividendes
en termes de richesse restituer aux
actionnaires merci nous avoir apporté
cet éclairage philippe béchade menacé
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france direction paris à présent le
quartier de stalingrad est en proie
depuis deux nuits et des tirs de mortier
visant les trafiquants de drogue les
scènes se déroulaient venus de flandre
dans le 19ème arrondissement en dépit
d'un plan traque mis en place en
septembre 2019 par les autorités les
attroupements de personnes liées à la
vente ou à la consommation de drogue se
poursuivent inlassablement sous l'oeil
des riverains excédés dont certains sont
arrivés d'ailleurs à un point de non
retour
un phénomène qui dure depuis maintenant
des années créant un climat évidemment
d'insécurité je vous propose d'écouter
le témoignage de l'un d'entre eux juste
des gens qui font leurs besoins dans la
rue il ya des scènes de prostitution en
pleine rue de la consommation de drogues
en pleine rue on va appuyer des prêtres
et la maman d'interprétation c'est que
depuis deux trois jours devant la cramif
où il ya vraiment des concentrations un
énorme de de problème tous les soirs il
y en a qui ont craqué et
donc je sais qu'il ya eu des tirs de
mortier c'est probablement quelques
riverains riverains je sais pas qui n'en
pouvaient plus parce que parce qu'ils
sont réveillés toutes les nuits le
lendemain il se réveille au milieu des
ordures les gens avec qui discuter mais
mon âme
tout le monde est épuisé épuisé
psychologiquement épuisée physiquement
en journée on sait que
on est au milieu de ce trafic permanent
de drogue et de la consommation de
drogues que ça se fait en à ciel ouvert
et on va pas les choses s'améliorer on
voit pas de on voit pas de lutte
efficace contre le deal se fait en
pleine rue où paradoxalement que les
dealers sont même pas masquer en ce
moment et on en parle de ses problèmes à
stalingrad avec nos invités c'est
l'objet de notre face à face ce soir
nous sommes avec frédéric français
membre du collectif 19 collectif de
riverains du 19e contre l'insécurité et
l'insalubrité les incivilités et le
crack bonsoir frédéric france elle merci
d'être avec nous à vos côtés pierre
henry président de france fraternité
bonsoir à vous aussi merci d'être là les
trafiquants de rock ciblés par les
riverains dont plus de recours ni de
confiance en la police
une situation on sent qu'il peut
dégénérer avec des livres 1 qui se font
désormais justice eux-mêmes cette
amérique france elle alors pas tout à
fait je pense pas qu'on puisse parler
réellement de se faire justice soi même
c'est plus en fait une
le fait d'être a excédé quoi part par la
présence en fait de tous ses dessous
tous ces toxicomanes et deux touchés
dealers qui fait que les les riverains
en fait on a envie de les chasser e par
tous les moyens mais pas vraiment en
fait se faire justice soi même ce qu'ils
veulent en fait c'est vraiment en fait
être entendu par la police par les
pouvoirs publics et par les associations
est en fait que tous ces gens
comprennent en fait qu' on ne peut pas
accueillir tous les soirs plus de des
centaines de toxicomanes en mode ses
fenêtres sans pouvoir réagir que on a
envie de dormir parfois
et oui on vous comprend bien pierre
henry président de france près ternie t1
vous gérer mes questions évidemment des
migrants il y en a beaucoup dans ce
quartier est ce que on peut lier les
deux phénomènes
clairement on ne peut pas du tout lié
les deux phénomènes se cette question du
crack est présente à paris depuis des
aînés et il faut bien dire que les
pouvoirs publics en général sont en
échec sur cette question je comprends
l'énervement
l'exaspération des riverains mais les
enfants lorsque j'entends dire où aller
chasser par tous les moyens
j'invite évidemment à la réflexion il y
a un plan de crack qui a été mis en
place à paris qui ne donne pas encore
toute sa mesure et qui en gros nous dit
quoi nous dit qu'aujourd'hui il ya une
salle de consommation pour 12 millions
d'habitants
en ile de france et il faudrait d'autres
salles de consommation sécuriser les
fameuses celle de chopin dont il y en a
une
oui c'est des salles de consommation
sécurisées et il y en a qu'une qui
aujourd'hui se trouve aux alentours de
l'hôpital lariboisière qui pose des
problèmes d'ailleurs à l'environnement
parce que encore une fois vous avez une
seule salle de shoot pour 12 millions
d'habitants on ile de france
ensuite vous avez introduit un lien
entre migrants et consommateurs et
dealer de crack qui n'a strictement rien
à faire là en l'occurrence vous avez une
population migrante qui parfois peut se
retrouver en situation de précarité qui
touche 3 facile pour l'ensemble des
dealers il n'y a pas d' amalgame à faire
mais je comprends encore une fois
l'agacement je crois pas cependant que
se faire justice soi même
soit une solution en république et je
pense que c'est autour d'une table avec
l'ensemble des autorités
concerné qu'il faut trouver une solution
au plus vite
et cette solution elle réside à la fois
dans la prise en charge des toxicomanes
avec des moyens adaptés elle réside dans
la chasse aux dealers et dans la mise en
place d'un véritable plan d'hébergement
qui ne laisse aucune personnes précaires
à proximité de ces dealers qui sont des
proies faciles
frédéric france elle vous comprenez les
arguments de de monsieur pierre henry
vous êtes en accord avec lui sur le
terrain qu'est ce qui se passe
concrètement parce que c'est vrai que ce
plan crack il a été quand même lancée il
ya maintenant deux trois ans
manifestement il ne porte pas ses fruits
qu'est ce qui coince sur le terrain à
l'option sur le plan du plan crack ce
qui pose souci essentiellement c'est
c'est que les associations même si elles
interviennent sur le terrain
effectivement en fait n'interviennent
pas réellement pour les sortir de leur
toxicomanie
ils interviennent en fait pour les aider
à ne pas en fait avoir de nouvelles
maladies en fait part à leur
consommation c'est-à-dire en leur
donnant en fait du matériel stérilisé en
leur donnant en fait des des moyens sera
en fête pour pouvoir consommer pour
pouvoir consommer il leur apporte
également en fait de nourriture de façon
plus ou moins sauvages en fait c'est qui
les fixe aussi à certains endroits mais
les ans site en fait à se concentrer
encore plus et ensuite et surtout en
fait le gros problème en fait c'est
qu'il n'ya pas de suivi c'est à dire
qu'on fait moi je les vois en fait très
clairement depuis ma fenêtre très
régulièrement quand il ya des
distributions les les toxicomanes arrive
traînent leur kit est reparti aussi vite
il n'y a pas de discussions en fait avec
l'association il n'y a pas au fait de
d'interactions
j'ai même vu en fait la preuve le coup
en fait en étant descendu lors d'une
distribution
la dra en fait c'est donc une autre
association humanitaire
je suis descendu en fait j'ai vu les
toxicomanes traité en fait les bénévoles
en fait de l'association est la limite
de comme si c'était en fait leurs
obligés c'est à dire ouais donne moi en
fait du quart nord-ouest a pas de 42
quoi sur mes chaussures
ce n'est pas acceptable loi n'importe
quoi je me casse
comment est ce que ça veut ça n'est pas
normal de parler comme ça en fait nos
associations et c'est surtout en fait on
voit bien qu'il ya un gros problème
c'est à dire qu'il leur fournisse certes
ce dont ils ont besoin pour survivre
mais ils n'essayent pas de les sortir en
fait de la de la rue ils les
entretiennent dans la rue surtout salle
sociaux oui personne n'entretient mais
les toxicomanes les personnes malades
dans la rue la vérité c'est que vous ne
pouvez pas contraindre ces gens à suivre
des programmes des processus de
désintoxication
s'ils ne veulent ne le veulent pas et
que par ailleurs lee l'usma partie aux
jets parents qui me semble qu'il ya des
lois que la consommation de drogues en
fait n'est pas autorisée en france qui
subissent en fait il ya quelque chose à
faire quand même
je veux bien en fait on peut on ne
puisse pas en fait les obliger à se
sortir de la toxicomanie en revanche en
fait il me semble qu'il ya un moyen
aussi de leur demander de ne pas le
faire en plein milieu de la rue mais il
y a de toute façon à trouver une
solution et c'est aux autorités alain au
préfet de police à la mairie de paris de
trouver cette solution en liaison
évidemment avec les usa les les
riverains ça paraît tout à fait évident
nous n'avons fait collectivement que
déplacer le problème depuis trois ans le
il y toxicomanes se trouvait sur une
colline appelé d'ailleurs le lieu dit
appeler la colline à la porte de la
chapelle la fermeture de la colline à la
porte de la chapelle a contribué
simplement à disperser les populations
et elles sont venues se regrouper pour
partie à stalingrad sous les fenêtres de
ce monsieur et de l'environnement et je
comprends la difficulté mais je voudrais
que l'on n'entende la chose suivante à
partir du moment où on veut traiter le
problème comme ça s'est fait dans
d'autres capitales dans le monde entier
il faut d'autres salles de consommation
sécurisé répartis dans l'ensemble de
l'ile-de-france est par ailleurs très
clairement je répète il faut évidemment
traquer les dealers faut arrêter que ce
lieu qui est un staline à devienne un
lieu de rendez-vous pour l'ensemble des
consommateurs de france voire d'europe
ce n'est pas possible c'est pas une
destination touristique et donc c'est
autour d'une table qu'il faut trouver
les solutions et donc j'invite ce
monsieur qui représente aujourd'hui les
riverains à un dialogue apaisé il faut
trouver une solution et manifestement
tiré au mortier sur pardonnez moi mais
mes blé ce cas là pour défendre ce
monsieur parce qu'il est là tout seul
pour se défendre en feuilles mais
l'immeuble plutôt l'air plutôt pacifique
a priori et ma foi quand on la voit là
ce genre de problème et qu'on n'arrive
pas à dormir de la nuit on imagine que
c'est une situation qui est très
compliqué est-ce que vous vous sentez
clairement abandonné par les pouvoirs
publics est ce que quartier stalingrad
est clairement devenu une zone 2
l'endroit comme on la décrit parfois du
nord ont baissé sur les propos de madame
dati problème oui mais une france elle
vous avez ce sentiment là vous oui moi
personnellement j'ai ce sentiment là je
vais vous expliquer pourquoi entre
autres c'est que je suis allé au contact
en fait justement fait de ces personnes
toxicomanes
pour une fois on fait effectivement j'ai
vu en fait une fois en fait dans le parc
en bas de chez moi une personne en fait
qui était visiblement toxicomanes qui
était visiblement sorti de l'hôpital en
fait certainement par une fenêtre ou
d'une manière détournée puisqu'elle tu
as encore habillées en tenue d'hôpital
et elles étaient couvertes en fait d'une
maladie je veux pas je suis pas médecin
mais il semblerait que ça soit une sorte
de l'est prophète très contagieux ce
dont elle était couverte sur surtout le
crâne
je suis descendu je me suis dit ce n'est
pas possible en fait de laisser une
personne comme ça en fait déambuler dans
le parc
il faut que quelqu'un l'aide donc je
suis descendu je me suis approché j'ai
demandé en fait si quelqu'un la
connaissez s'il y avait moyen de faire
quelque chose pour elle l'a en fait j'ai
été entouré par en fait donc une dizaine
de personnes toxicomanes qui m'ont
bizarrement fait entourer pour me
protéger pour me laisser parler avec
cette personne là j'ai discuté avec
cette personne là et n'ayant aucun autre
moyen j'ai pris mon téléphone et j'ai
donc appelé les pompiers
les pompiers m'ont dit monsieur en fait
c'est une toxicomane laissez la
tranquille rentrez chez vous j'ai fait
bon c'est pas possible donc j'ai appelé
la police
la police ils m'ont dit monsieur
veuillez laisser les lignes d'urgence
tranquille on va pas se déplacer c'est
une toxicomane laissez la tranquille de
repartent
je ne sais pas acceptable en fait ça
vous avez des personnes en fait en
grande souffrance qui sont dans le parc
et nous riverains en fait quand on
essaye d'intervenir de les aider d'une
manière ou d'une autre
en fait on déjà on n'en a pas les moyens
et en plus quand on essaye d'appeler à
l'aide en fait les services de l'état il
nous disait monsieur raccrocher enfin
que vous êtes gentil mais restez chez
vous regarder la télé et vous occupez
pas des gens dans la rue ce n'est pas
acceptable
ce n'est pas acceptable il faut
absolument que non seulement en fait les
forces de police interviennent en fait
auprès des dealers mais qu'en fait les
forces
gouvernementale je ne sais pas
interviennent auprès de ces personnes
toxicomanes pour les obliger
en fait assez à ceux à se soigner ils ne
sont pas conscients fait qu'ils sont
malades
il faut les obliger à se soigner ils
sont gravement malade il met en péril la
santé et la vie en fait des riverains il
faut les faire soigner
merci en tout cas à tous les matins
pardonnez mon arrive malheureusement la
fin de cette émission on est tenu par
les un petit peu par les horaires merci
en tout cas à tous les deux frédéric
français les pierre-henri d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france reste
avec nous dans quelques instants un
point complet sur l'actualité de la
journée
[Musique]
non
en avril aura lieu le 60e anniversaire
du vol de youri gagarine en ayant eu la
chance de m'entraîner avec nos collègues
russes j'ai vraiment plongé dans une
atmosphère où j'ai vécu auprès de méroé
gagarine était présent à chaque point de
bâtiments de salles de sport de place de
la cité des étoiles moi je crois
beaucoup dans la diplomatie scientifique
et quand vous parlez de la coopération
scientifique sur la station bien enroulé
une station spatiale